70 bénévoles étaient au rendez-vous tant
attendu de la pêche annuelle du complexe
piscicole de la fédération
départementale de pêche d'indre et loire
chacun a sa mission pour que la pêche
soit miraculeuse et les costauds sont
affectés à la gestion du niveau d'eau de
l'étang et alimente la pêcherie en
poisson qui est du poisson qui arrivent
mais faut garder un peu d'eau c'est un
peu compliqué donc et gérer justement
les legatt sont derrière qui pêche à
l'épuisette voilà premier barrage de la
pêcherie épuisette à la main les
pêcheurs réceptionne les poissons
déversés par la bonde en flèche devant
la grille tous les poissons présentes on
les met dans les lacs les d backs s'en
va autre
hic est qu'il ya des grosses pièces
comme les bonbons chez vous avez vu ou
des grosses cartes sont directement
mises à part parce que tous les écrase
tous les tous les petits gars dont
le porteur amène les bacs de poissons en
vrac sur des tables c'est là que sont
séparé les gros gars dont les petits
gardons les tanches les brèmes les black
bass et quelques écrevisses une mission
digne d'une plateforme votre question
c'est quoi
notre triage du poisson par espèces par
grosseur
catégorie en apparence et la bonne
humeur qui règnent sauf que le niveau
d'eau est très bas cette année dans les
temps il faut faire vite pour que les
poissons est assez d'oxygène aux grosses
concentrations de poissons l'heure peu
d'eau et il faut pas les laisser mourir
c'est tout un an le travail de mis à la
poubelle non que j'aime pas trop ça
il faut jongler il n'y a pas d'eau et
faut se débrouiller de sauver tous les
pressions c'est tout simple il y a
quinze ans leur et empoissonnement
concerné 15 tonnes de poissons mais pour
cette année la prise est moitié moindre
et ça ne va pas en s'arrangeant
on a de très mauvaises conditions
atmosphériques
hydraulique au cours de l'année là ça
devient de problématique pour nous la
sécheresse il ya plus d'eau et donc on
ne sait même pas si cette année on va on
va remettre en eau les temps si on n'a
pas d'eau aux arrivées dans dans nos
petits cours d'eau qui alimente
justement se détend ça va nous poser des
problèmes c'est une crainte que doivent
partager les dix sept mille adhérents
annuel de la fédération
le bandeau privera peut-être 2012 d'une
nouvelle pêche miraculeuse un manque à
pêcher sur les 3000 kilomètres de
fleuves et cours d'eau du département